hello hello
private private here we go
a b c d e f g h i h i j k j k l m n o
hey
ajk LM
hello hello
private private here we go
a b c d e f g h i h i j k j k l m n o
hey
ajk LM
hello hello
[Music]
private private here we go
a b c d e f g h i h i j k j k l m n o
hey
hey hello ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the show this is Hans Kim we are
coming to you live ladies from
my home
and gentlemen welcome to the show sorry
about that
uh this show is really about drugs and
alcohol and
how to do it better
and how to get people into it that might
not already be into it
human beings
um
so what's going on nowadays is there's a
poop girl in Austin
she became famous for rolling around in
poop on 6th Street
the horse is there take shits on the
sidewalk and the road mostly the road
there's just [__] right there horses
just don't give a [__] about
[__]
KT
well the episodes haven't come out yet
but
let's just say that there's a
competition going on for my spot
and
there's a lot of drama associated with
it so stay tuned my friends
don't want to spoil anything but I'm
doing fine
I'm just having a great time in life in
general
so yeah there's a poop girl she's just
rolling around in poop not really a big
deal
apparently herbivore [__] isn't as
disgusting as uh omnivore or carnivore
[__] it's like cow [__] is just normal
it's like fun to play with people in
Africa throw elephant dung at each other
and that's fun and not dangerous
but yeah I mean there was horseshit on
this on the road and then this girl was
playing with it so
it's fun everyone loved it it's not a
big deal
I think people like to tell women
when they're being disgusting because
that's like devastating for a woman
to be called disgusting
so they like to use that power a lot of
people like to
such shame I think and make women feel
bad
because women make them feel bad so they
get back at them by being like you're
gross you're a harlot you're a [__]
hunts came to your friends yell while
talking normally to you
well if they were yelling they wouldn't
be talking normally
my parents are Asian They Don't Really
yell they are very quiet and polite
people you got to keep the spot you're
hilarious thank you I'm trying but
well you'll see in the episodes to come
no spoilers here but let's just say
let's just say there's some strong punch
lines in the [__] community
but uh yeah the horse girl
so here's a conundrum do you turn on red
receipts or not do you leave them off
because
it's like having more information is
good but sometimes it's not good because
then you know when someone reads your
[__] and then you just want to be like
hey I just I was just reading it
but I wasn't gonna respond till later
but that doesn't mean I hate you and
then like they're like oh you read it
and sometimes I don't want to know if
they read it I just want to send it to
them let them deal with it on their own
time however they deal with them they
can come back to me I don't even know
when they read it because that might
hurt my feelings
so I can lead a whole to culture but you
can't make her think
a horror to culture
um
all my Korean friends man they had some
loud conversations
yeah I guess Koreans can get loud
then why are they known to be polite I
think everyone can be loud but Asians
are more often quieter than more other
races
often do you hire a maid to clean your
house not very often I need to start
doing that
especially the common areas
just because if
if if we leave it up to the roommates to
figure out who's gonna clean what then
no one's gonna do it because no one
wants to
be going through the indignity of doing
more work than others that's like
ingrained in us to be
so
despised so we're like we don't want to
be doing the most work
we want to be doing the least work
um
there has to be a way of understanding
the complexities of the situation that
we're in there has to be a way of doing
this and this is a part of the process
there are many different ways of
understanding the complexities and we
have to utilize the methods at our
disposal that come to the proper
conclusion there are artistic beings in
the mix and they are a part of our
atmosphere
laughs
that's just some of the nonsense that I
write trying to reach 2 000 words a day
how often do you hire me it's gonna be
the guy with the speaker my guess
anyways say a funny joke congrats on
your success so Bud hello from Vista
California
so here's a funny joke what's uh
how do you get a
taco
into a butthole
you shove it into a Mexican
um my African friends once told me he
was loud because he was used to yelling
at the birds
motivations be loud
Asians aren't loud
um
anyways
you know what happened to the Titanic
who knows
I just want to know
if the captain of the Titanic
was Reckless because he was going so
fast
when there were so many icebergs around
when there were warnings of icebergs
I saw an Instagram video of a boat
hitting a windmill in the middle of the
ocean and when you're just looking at
the boat it just looks like it hits it
it like just bounces off but when you
look at the cabin camera you can see the
dude
on his phone or something and he goes
flying across the room just because that
little bump so like a little bump on a
big boat is still like a big deal
it's like a lot of force so you hit a
Iceberg and then if it's the captain's
fault then he's like he's an idiot he
should have been more careful with this
brand new bow to not go bumping into
things
like
the thing about the thing is that boats
are doing are susceptible to low ground
and
things to run into
but I guess that's a lot of things
did he started getting booked for comedy
shows so the best way to get booked for
comedy shows is to go to a comedy show
and
have people be like oh my God that's
chandray Fawcett
that's shandre Fawcett put him around
the show
um I think the best way to get on a
comedy show is to
show people that you're funny by being
on a comedy show and being funny
um another great way to get on the
comedy show is to become a regular on
kill Tony
another great way to get on comedy shows
is to be funny
in a comedic sense or have a large
following or we have a large Tech talk
or just be friends with people and
convince them of your artistic genius
and convince them that they're investing
on the ground floor in your brand
and that you are a brilliant comedian
and they could benefit from helping you
he could get on a comedy show by
sleeping with somebody
you gotta pick the right person to just
sleep with anyone expecting to get on a
comedy show you gotta sleep with someone
that has a comedy show or has access to
one
if you get on a comedy show by
you know
being a part of the scene and being
known as someone that gets booked and
they're like oh I'm booking a show let
me go through my booked people's list
and then start booking getting booked
because other people book you
um basically you need to prove to people
that you can be a positive addition to
their show or to their life
or to their genitals
but yeah I mean if I were you I would
try to convince people that you could
help the show make it better
not make it worse
and that you have something that not a
lot of other people have and that your
perspective on the world is unique and
that you have insightful insights into
the
and citing incidents of our time
anyways how do you build your name in
Seattle's comedy scene
well I built my name in the Seattle
comedy scene by doing
Music open mics and
just practicing and getting more stage
time than everyone else and writing more
than everyone else
um I guess you can't say that I wrote
more than anyone else maybe I did maybe
I didn't who cares
but it probably was going up more than
anyone else except for like headliners
because I was doing these Music open
mics that would be like a year in less
than a year and I was doing 15 minutes
at a music open mics
and I'd be the only comedian there
and I would hit like two or three a
night and the musicians would hate me
sometimes they'd be like oh my God this
kid they'd all be like old people just
doing their little music
and I'd be there like trying to talk
about politics and dicks and stuff
how do you develop with a fetish what
happened to that British female comedian
that tried to roast you and kill Tony
do you have any sort of like Taoist
rituals
um I have a Taoist ritual where I Korean
food
which is a food that's ancestral to my
people the ancestors
what happened to that British female
comedian she's doing great
um
she is uh not interested in dating me
obviously
she made that clear
so that's good to know
she's a comedian she goes all over the
world you can follow her on Instagram
very funny very
cool person that does not want to date
me
uh there's a lot of those they have a
they have a club and they all talk about
how they don't want to date me
it's called women in general because no
woman wants to date me just kidding
some women do you come to Pennsylvania
anytime anywhere around Pittsburgh I
actually did The Burning Bridges
Festival in Pittsburgh
that's where I learned about yinzers
um what's up Hans are you allowed to
smoke bud over there if so what's your
preference
um I just ran out of weed unfortunately
but yes I've been smoking a lot if you
couldn't tell
I am smoking up a storm I've been pretty
high
feeling good
just trying to enjoy life
my supply chain girl is still my
girlfriend she is so beautiful and so
lovely
and I love her so much
and hopefully she goes with me to Round
Rock tonight
because
otherwise we won't be able to see each
other tonight because she has a normal
job
let's grab lunch next week when you are
free
um
lunch can be fun
so yeah I mean
I think
um the supply chain girl is amazing and
wonderful and I hope that she continues
to date me
um Boston yes I hope to be going to
Boston
you can go in the ocean and be the worst
if you're doing your best and everything
works out you can be the worst marine
animal in the water that day or you
could be on land and be an apex predator
and do everything your body was designed
to do
thing about the ocean is that we're not
supposed to be there why would you want
to be somewhere where you're not the
best like do you play basketball if
you're five foot four or do you are you
a horse jockey like why are you going to
where nobody wants you nobody thinks
you're cool there nobody's trying to
kiss you under the bottom of the ocean
it's not where we're supposed to go
there's no point in putting the human
body into places it's not supposed to go
so
someone's here
okay
what kind of money around it's a
Kawasaki versus
yes
differences
holy [__] well I also have a
bigger dual sport bike and said okay
well it's a dual support uh it's like a
dirt bikes I can go on the street
um so it has like lights and license
plate yeah exactly yeah
did you bring the Drone I did
I think we can get a flight okay I hope
so dude there's nothing else like so I
got it down to the translator
but um
like I don't know which which is the arm
switch we had to like plug it in click
here and see like what
happens yeah
oh my God
for the chair
so are you okay being on the live stream
okay all right
yeah
hopefully we keep it fine but there
shouldn't be anything like that stops US
hey what's up guys this is my friend
who's helping me with the Drone
do you want to introduce yourself what's
up I'm Nico
he's been on kill Tony
recently
so he's helping me fly my drone I was
just talking about how we shouldn't like
just go places
like with uh our human body like the
ocean it's not where we're supposed to
be yes there's no point in sending us to
Venus send a robot and a camera
put like sensor sensory inputs on it and
then put you in a VR suit and you can
feel like you're in Venus but be able to
breathe
we're stuck here just get used to it
stop making Earth shitty so that you
want to leave it
can you close that door yeah
do you want to react to some videos
it's good
are you allowed to just show YouTube
videos on YouTube
that I couldn't tell you
what's up YouTube videos that aren't
music this week
this guy is so [__] confusing
I was like trying to put everything back
oh yeah
it's one of those DJI bags yeah there's
a it's it's like three in one so it can
be like a shoulder bag it can be a
backpack and it can be whatever
but
it's not good at any of them
yeah there's too many pockets that lead
nowhere it looks cool
yeah
so the batteries got fried
I don't know how that happened
but I wasn't even they were just sitting
right here
that you controlled everything to you
because this is normal room temperature
I don't know why there's a plug right
there
yeah but I just don't know what I did to
[__] it up
on like a non-balance setting which is
kind of sketch yeah because you don't
want to blow it up but um
I've done it before and brought
batteries back but it's kind of like
so another idea that I'm playing with is
some people in restaurants and
businesses don't accept cash oh yeah
they had a have a bill in Seattle where
you have to accept cash if you're a
business
what do you think that is you think
that's just like no Brown nosers that
just love registering everything to the
IRS or do you think it's people that are
like don't like homeless people or poor
people
I kind of think it's
probably in Seattle I was in Seattle
during covert and I kind of think that
that was more of a coveted thing like
the people in Seattle just it's dirty
money's dirty exactly that's how they
feel and I guess maybe they thought that
the homeless people with cash well I
think like uh
it's
like the covet thing is like it wasn't
even a thing like you don't get coveted
from giving people money
I never got it
if it's through the air through the air
you don't have to guess anymore
but you can Google it
but no I think uh yeah maybe there it's
a carryover from the thing but it's good
to have an analog version especially
with something as delicate a society you
don't want to just go all digital
it's gonna collapse at some point yeah
you gotta have a backup
let's just wait throwing things on the
bed
yeah that's what they said
if it's powered through the USB it's you
know that because yeah make sure
so uh did you bring extra batteries
yeah
if not we can still get it made to the
cheers
weren't that one of them is charging
okay this one is kind of like
so you know how to use that charging
thing too
yeah they're all kind of different but
bass so how did you get into drones
watching YouTube videos uh trying to get
into powered paragliding Howard hell
yeah dude have you seen it no I see you
basically you have like a lawnmower
motor with a repeller on it with a
backpack and then you have a parasail
yeah and you just take off from wherever
yeah
and so I was looking to get into that
and I saw some videos of people racing
fpv drones through the forest and I
thought man that seems way safer a lot
more affordable
and so I went for it yeah I just found I
found a group of people in town that
were
into it I love drones that's what we're
talking about like going to Venus and
[__] we don't need to go to Venus right
yeah control it and you can see it yeah
it's like all we need because that's the
Drone thing like you don't you're not
flying but you feel like you're flying
and then if you go with the Drone and
scope it out and it seems safe
then you go to penis did you just look
that rock silent is that the only thing
you keep it around
yeah
I was wondering
dude I had this girl in my house the
other day and she she was asking if she
could lick my rock salt lamps and I was
like
I guess if you want but do you have a
lot of girls coming to your house is
that a humble brag uh no it's not a not
a lot but
I mean
an okay I'm out I guess
I said give us a one lighter Hans
give us a one minor
damn dude
here's a one-liner
hey go [__] your mother
yeah that'll work anyway so the battery
is charging should we hook up this
we should look at all the way this is
okay what do we need
USBC
uh yeah probably
yeah
oh here we go
you know what firmware or what I'm
software they're using on this is it
betaflight
yeah probably yeah
yeah that's uh Nazgul
um yeah my best one-liner is do you know
what a clone of Willy is no oh right
okay so it's like it's a kit that you
buy to make a clone of your dick like it
comes with silicone and then Dental
alginate
to okay
so my pickup line is that I had to buy
extra silicone for my cloneability kit
but normally people don't know what it
is so it's like I have to explain that
to them too an extra what I had to buy
extra income with an F silicone and come
with a silicone yeah it's like it's a
kit and it comes with like so you have
extra silicone that you need because
your dick small
exactly
but the other way
what other way it's not I bought more
silicone because my dick's not small
uh you got yeah you got leftover
silicone no I didn't have anyone yeah no
no there's none left over I used all of
it
your dick is either big or small but
you're mentioning the size of it which
is funny
either way yeah
it's like that Werner Herzog oh hell
yeah this is uh [__] yeah
I'm so glad it's being polite do this
real quick
can you do that again so you can wear
waffles
and this isn't the camera yeah oh [__]
okay look so you can see the Drone
doing what it's doing here getting ready
to go to Venus yes
this is the Venus copter
17. and it looks like this is a good
page to have it on because then you can
see if it's actually set up correctly
like let's see facing this way down yes
okay so my God already puts backwards
all right and then if it's not level you
can
put it on a level surface and then
calibrate the accelerometer
so like if you click
that and then it'll
thank God
is get your own keyboard and mouse
right over there do you see that
keyboard mouse should be somewhere over
there as well
huh
sick
yes
it's a lot over here
you gotta do
okay
I love it
yeah this is this is good I'm glad that
it was
it's already got beta flight
it's already a [__] thing
oh see come on over here
foreign
it's a little [__] on the big screen
uh maybe
I think it's just about that
[__] chill okay so that's that's good
to know that it's doing that so it's
like constantly
they should be
it should be well so that
backwards
uh no I didn't what's going on
so actually I met up sorry a lot
I'm trying to make it look good
like that not spinning not like that
okay it's like a bullet I can chill
okay
yeah just on up on stage I was just
walking through the alley back when you
guys used to stand in the valley
that was the last end-to-end mouth yeah
people will ever know
but yeah you can't have people in the
alley in Texas dude I only sang it twice
and we went to Valley once oh and that
second time they're gone uh 50
since that's right
either
okay so I think it's p-a-e-r which means
throttle aileron elevator and roll like
that's we'll see right there so and the
role means that this way this way
so if you go like this that's your
that's the problem oh so this thing the
roll is the throttle the throttle so
we're going to change it to p a
e r which state is
you're so Channel mapping you need to
change this to uh that's how everyone
does the uh [__] see I usually use free
stack
but I usually use risky we'll just try
all of them I don't know why I'm
correcting you know more than I do you
know I call it personally too I just
watch your color I didn't know if you
were up on your your terminology yeah
I heard on the video somewhere
dropped in the spinning thing
okay so the battle is correct
the pitch
yep then and around perfect so that's
the uh oh sorry that's yeah that's like
the red yellow yeah yeah that's the
funny sounding one yeah and that's just
what turning your head basically and
then pitch forward or backwards okay
pitch what's pitch
oh your nose and so if you pitch up
you're gonna throttle up and you're
gonna go straight up or pitch back and
throttle up you're gonna I mean that's
depending on how fast you do it you're
either gonna
just bend backwards or you can do what's
called a
okay what it's called but what do you do
if you want to go straight up
loop-de-loop or uh like this back worker
um oh I would just hit like I mean you
could change the rates like how many
degrees per second the Drone turns yeah
um so I would change the rates to a
little bit higher rate and all you need
to do is like hit this like and click
and you'll like flip over uh see slap
you down inverted or whatever
into a power Loop yeah that's that's
what it's called Power yeah like I like
to do those over under bridges like you
go under the bridge and then filter you
can do that oh hell yeah okay
yeah
I'll have to I'll Define
and it's your system you know this is
good so now we need to see which switch
is the arm switch
let's run shut up here whichever one you
feel is like the quickest because if you
need to design your drone really quickly
it's nice to just know so I'm guessing
like where you're right or left-handed
right let's try this
yeah okay sounds good that's real big
yeah I'm so box three
so you need to say
boom
I think that's cool or you could have a
button if you prefer that in order to
switch I guess a button might be better
because you can set theology off from
yeah you can take the switches for
different modes yeah so this one goes in
and then it goes out yeah that'd be
about a sudden I'm
okay
like after this
itch
chandray Fawcett asks what made you keep
going to open mites probably the Love of
the Game just saying jokes and seeing if
it works and being able to control
people with my mouth absolutely
yeah and if you love that you can keep
going doing comedy forever and that's a
game so if you can enjoy doing comedy
that you have a heads uh you have an
advantage and it's like a lot of people
don't they just want success and it's so
so lame in the south
Hollow you know like you're talking to a
zombie yeah it's pretty appearance I
guess dude
four
so before you leave can you send me a
recommendation for battery that I should
buy for sure because these I just bought
yeah yeah tattoos or whatever they're
like the that's the brand that people
are gonna push you because they sponsor
like everybody yeah but they're really
not the best value
um the composition of the battery itself
I forget what it is but there's like a
superior material that they use for the
the other one yeah and it's called
wrapping graphic yeah so what's the
brand that you recommend I would
recommend China hobby line so it sounds
sex but they're really good too they're
the best like those batteries can take
up China's so not what you want to hear
with electronics but then if you think
like sometimes you feel the wrapping
back on those
and it's like the same
yeah probably sometimes so I have a 4S
right and success is like Optimal those
are faster yeah because it's okay so
drones work on the principle of KV which
is RPMs per volt so the more volts you
have the faster our games right so yeah
the six the six I've never found the six
has before but iPhone 5S all sold out or
else I would have got it but yeah when I
bought this I was like getting
everything so fast then I got everything
and it was a pain to set up and I was
like [__] this it's kind of do you um
um do you have is this your first epic
here yes I think I crashed my what do
you call non-fpv drones just the
photography Journey yes photography yeah
those are nice but anyways they don't do
everything I want to do they don't
and you can't fly fpv really I mean you
can look at your phone but there's a
delay
originally and then that will cause them
to crash
yeah
um yeah I like
I like the Drone I like the concept of
it I like how easy it is to fly you're
gonna shoot your pants when you get out
and race actually or just like go around
the track or like grab some trees and
similar to your race I haven't raced
anywhere in Austin but I have all this
stuff to set up track we can just go to
a field or something because they're
like you have to have a lead no you know
we could just go up there just have to
do you still know people I did I raced a
professional day yeah I I don't know you
know bent over and yeah yeah
Amari no I mean it's since since I've
flown professionally it's been I know
I'm CK yeah but do you know of him no I
was a Korean oh no and his videos are
amazing his videos are the best you guys
like Freestyle videos yeah
and he's like just good at racing too I
have some like old freestyle videos on
YouTube and some German or some racing
videos yeah I wish I asked you before
okay so angle is like
so your flip over yeah that's when you
can actually flip over it's like full
like if you push the the pitch forward
it stays forward until you take it back
so with Horizon mode that's going to be
like flying a photography drone that's
where it auto levels itself so if you
let go the sticks it goes back to level
so I'll set that as like an option that
you can put it on
um so photography mode whereas it's not
photography mode yeah exactly wow it's
like race race like you can't do you
can't do freestyle like flips and [__]
in photography right because the Drone
wants to keep itself level
uh so it's like that mode is really cool
to have and know where it's at because
like if you're flying around and you hit
a tree or something or you hit a race
gate or anything and you spin out of
control usually you don't know what's
going on because you have goggles on you
just like spinning you can hit the that
mode and then the Drone will at least
level yeah and then you can power up or
down but the thing is with that
photography drone this thing doesn't go
down or it doesn't stay there yeah you
just got to be yeah yeah exactly so this
one you have to you have to although I
just gotta keep going down but at least
having the Horizon mode like takes one
aspect of like what you use so is that a
button oh yeah it's gonna be this switch
right here that's the switch Yeah so
like when it's
yeah so like I'll do this one you're
like when you turn it on this will be
would you prefer it to be like race mode
or do you prefer it to be Auto love mode
when you first turn it on uh right okay
so we'll have that
sentences
hello
whenever you go to add another mode
instead of searching for the correct
Channel you can just put the switch and
it'll pick it up okay so it ends
when you first turn on race mode
next one is how to level photography
mode and then we don't need to really
add it
so just to
um your drone probably has what's called
Turtle mode too
and that is if you flip over yeah you
can hit that until those times yeah it
freaks out in your pocket it'll pop out
okay so that's really nice if you're if
you land and if you land on like about
it for something is that a button you
just press it once yeah
no it's still on like one of the
switches okay usually it could be
whatever you want but uh
South Korea was great so foreign
Korea is amazing it's like people that
are like United at a base level but like
still this United have like you know all
the normal issues so it's like at least
they have some [__] figured out like
transportation is amazing there it's not
great though there's have so many cars
still they've really based it on America
there's way too many highways everyone's
driving it's crazy
but it's way better than like Vietnam I
heard I saw this video about it
like everyone in Vietnam is on the
surface so that everyone's driving
mopeds and cars but in Korea everyone's
underground oh that's sideways oh yeah
so it's even bigger than whatever but
there's less people on the surface it
doesn't seem as busy and everyone's just
getting to wherever they want to go
instead of being stuck in traffic and
everyone's not where they want to be
everyone's where they want to be they're
a lot happier I kind of think that
that's intentional here like that people
are kind of just like caught up like
it's not very efficient to get from
point eight point B in the US like any
City that I visited it just seems like
we could benefit more roundabouts or
building things closer together not
having giant parking lots doesn't make
sense not having giant highways that no
one wants to do the things too if it
doesn't make sense it's making somebody
dollars
I know I mean do you know like about
white flight and suburban sprawl I've
heard of smooth and straw how they were
like oh all the black people are moving
into the cities let's move on to the
suburbs and the highways connecting them
all yeah and then did you need to have a
car to get anywhere
and all the rich people can you know
just go into the city do what they have
to do and leave and all the people
living in the city are stuck here
it's like why don't make awesome cities
sort of like shitty
cities for people to zoom into now but
but yeah I mean America is like based on
torturing black people
John Collins Kim
uh
[__] magnet
buns is [__] men
yeah
these things but I've never heard about
a drone before but who knows hey ladies
future is changing take your goggles off
their normal glasses on it's it's
actually surprising the amount of women
that I give fpv goggles and like fly
around my backyard
that results in me getting laid Yeah you
control their world
it's like a Latin like I just took the
head yeah they could fly now everyone
wants to fly especially [__] what are
you doing do you trust me
if you trust me it's just hypnotizing
them they get naked
all right well I think they're good to
go all right let's pop on the propellers
uh let's test it first before we pop
I learned my blessing well yeah get it
away from anything that can get caught
Don't Unplug it oh I'm gonna put battery
in down see
if it does the things
make sure the motor is who is the
brother
the brother is Nico
comedian drone pilot
resident of Austin former resident of
Seattle you know I'm from Seattle
I think we talked about this
so is that a good drone you think I mean
it looks like it's well built yeah I
just bought it it's a dead cat formation
please
Queen
well it's never been flown hey yeah
that's right now it's like you almost
want to like break about or something
right away yeah and get that bad juju on
thick so the goggles work have you tried
okay this should work
what are the Gobles
hopefully they're charged or is the uh
but
so um
there's this
is it working
um
so uh how long have you been into drones
since like
2016. damn
has it gotten a lot better
uh other people have gotten a lot better
I kind of just stay the same well like
the same yeah for sure yeah I can't keep
up honestly I'm not I'm this I can
understand what's going on here but I
haven't made the job I'm like analog to
digital and I'm pretty sure this is all
digital so yeah so there's video
translations
I see you
oh my God that [__] is so loud
that's crazy that I'm seeing you right
now
shout outs Brian redband
I will be in town on Thursday
are you uh
are you a big fan of the uh local comedy
scene oh definitely yeah been nice going
out to Mike's and like watching people
get one here are you uh kill Tony fan
from before you move to Austin
watching kill Tony like last November
damn yeah last November yeah and I heard
about it on Rogan's podcast uh all right
time to go let me just check this show
out so you just got into comedy before
kill Tony I got into comedy in January
pandemic at the Shanghai room
wait there's that during the pandemic no
I always I mean I guess still
technically like it's always the
pandemic in Seattle but um but it was
after the pandemics after people went
really well so you're like brand new
yeah just just this last January exactly
five minutes isn't it crazy that there's
some parts of the country where the
pandemic [__] it so hard that it will
never be better than before the pandemic
it's crazy especially we were living at
the peak yeah of some cities yeah and
you'll never know what it's like to do
comedy in a functioning San Francisco
again yeah hey that's that's closer but
I don't know what what city is not doing
well yeah
negative March of it
those times one exactly
oh my God
oh my God this [__] is so freaking loud
yeah it's it's helpful if you lose it
yeah but
this not good for inside
that's like a [__] fire alarm
yeah
it's about five people Canadians
why does there have to be an arm switch
at all like can you just play it and
I thought the same thing but it is kind
of helpful to have an arm switch just
like like a safety especially if you're
racing like people keep their dreams and
he's like you're on a lane or something
and they're likely open and hit it like
I've actually shot my memes
oh my God so you just turn it off with
the button yeah
yes that is helpful
I got my new space for a shirt
goodbye now on Amazon
so this is saying that
the arm is on channel five
but there's really nothing yes
there's my drone
and [__] virtual reality
hey Hans are you into fpv drones or the
grandpa DJI drunk ones
both
both I don't know why you don't do both
I think if you do the old grandpa drones
then you gotta want to do flips oh for
sure yeah dude I went to one of these
drone meetups in Austin have you been no
they're all like old people I think I
have the DJ Adrian they fly DJI drones
and they just go up down left right
backward forward
and now I just run circles around them
but they already they know that they
exist they're more into like the
technical aspect of it they're more like
nerds about it it's more like a aircraft
you know toy aircraft
kind of thing it's really interesting
how it triggers different parts of your
brain and
different parts of society
these old guys seem like they'd be into
trains
as well
you got like Mountain Head juice heads
oh my gosh that I just sent to the
adrenaline rush of it all
feeling alive
where are you going after this you're
going back to your home
oh you brought up a motorcycle it's
gonna ask for a ride yeah you got a
helmet I do have a helmet thank you
how's it going do you have those things
I can hold on to on the side so I don't
have to hold on to you yeah like do
middle I have a box like on the back you
can say
yeah it's only gay if you make eye
contact which is impossible because
selected the mayor it's like Medusa it's
like Medusa if she turns UK I have a
joke about that all right
somebody just had to have been flat
chested right
because otherwise people would be
staring at our tits yeah like nothing
would begin
sticks yeah
Medusa she had big tits wouldn't be as
useful
okay
I've been working on it for a while and
anytime I tell people they're like this
Medusa like I have to give you a history
lesson first yeah I did a Mr Rogers joke
and it didn't work I think a lot of
people are
yeah
frame of reference is just important
hey you're on the air live on the Hans
Kim show what do you have to say for
yourself
what do you have to say for yourself
I guess you want to say anything
to me harmful or
incendiary coming to make it radio
to cause drama and Intrigue I'm just
kidding
uh
anyways are you gonna come pick me up or
do I have to go to you
okay I'll come to you but it might be a
while because I'm figuring this out
right now
my drone my friend came with my drone
and we're figuring it out streams
you can
because he has a motorcycle
do you want me to hug him very tight to
get back at you
it's cool bro I'm just biracial not
bisexual well now I don't want to do it
even less than I wanted to before
well this is on the air but I will talk
to you soon and uh I'll make my way over
there
that is true I'll text you
okay bye love you
so hard coordinating when to meet up
and be like are you doing more than I'm
doing that's why am I doing more than
your daily
like
you don't want to move in too quick but
you also
don't want to spend too much time apart
because it's like a little stressful and
inefficient
a lot of driving between places yes and
she go to park me she lives there where
you live uh North yeah so it's not easy
yeah that is
to do every day yeah I understand lately
I've just kind of thought
like okay if they're interested in me
they'll make the drive they'll make it
happen
you know it's just about it it's
stressing it out okay
so how's it going I met this you draw no
life
I'm sorry thank you um it's going all
right I don't really understand why it's
not letting me arm but
just like a woman yeah exactly exactly
like not letting your arm reversary is
this on the controller because I know I
was [__] with the controller a lot
like where you got before I gave it to
you
so this is the Drone
as you can see
on the screen if I tilt it down it goes
down
to that it goes up so there's a sensor
inside and it's sending all this
information to the computer
but if it doesn't send it to the
computer it has it in its little brain
and it figures out how to fly
so you know what I would do when I first
fly it is fly it in Horizon mode or
whatever you called it
because I know how to do that yeah the
throttle thing kind of scares me so I'm
glad that I can just switch it with a
flick of the switch
quickly I'm so excited
I'm gonna buy so many batteries I'm not
even gonna need a DJI I crashed mine I
sent it in I think it warranty it it's
hopefully they're like if it's not user
error it was a hundred percent user
error
well maybe they won't be able to tell I
just didn't even delete anything I was
like yeah
it's too sad yeah I wish I never record
my crashes because whenever I crash I'm
not doing anything I'm always crashing
when I'm like just getting it in there
you didn't set this did you this makes
arm that was already preset on there I
don't know probably I might have done it
thanks
dookie's lips are where all them fresh
grease collect
what does that mean amen
Fish Grease
I wish I didn't mess with that now
I think
this is not unless you know entry on the
network time
I got a Tango two
they call it a remote controller or a
receiver I guess
because it's receiving information but
it's also transmitting
I feel like it's more about transmitting
information
maybe that's the receiver I don't know
the terminology
I just know the noise it makes when it
takes off a taliban's head
but these aren't the drones that they're
using for that
DJI drones are the drones they're using
in a Ukraine right now
we've seen some of the videos for what
like did Ukraine Constance or are they
just mopping grenades yeah they have
pretty easy to put a Remote device on
there to like you can buy it on Amazon
they're like 30 bucks but the range on
those like is not super far yeah so this
would actually be better for dropping
grenades because you can set one of
these switches to draw to drop the thing
and you could have like long range on it
really these have better range than DJI
this probably has a pretty comparable
range I mean you're using DJI fpv stuff
yeah and then this is a pretty long
range isn't the limiting factor of the
battery
um yeah yeah Fair like how long you can
play so do they have a better but better
battery life than DJI
no you could buy a bigger battery like
this is a 1500 milliamp hour battery but
you could buy probably like an 1800 one
or you could build a battery
um but yeah honestly this drone I
wouldn't expect to be able to fly for
longer than like
seven minutes yeah just because well
they use these ones as suicide bombers
they just put a bomb on it and you guys
just crash it into something oh see that
seems yeah I can see that
yeah with your knowledge you could
probably build them for really cheap
it's super easy building I could
probably build a drone for 100 bucks or
less and you could use it as a homing
missile and just get good at it it'd be
like mess you know how Nest how's that
up be moving Super Smash
oh yeah the smash heads will know what
I'm talking about
what made you start stand up probably
being such a hilarious and talented
person
I'm sorry I just did it because I didn't
want a real job
that's here
so in Ukraine they have these DJI drones
they put a [__]
a [__] bomb on the other side
underside of it I think Russia has DJI
drones too I think China's selling them
to both
DJI is a Chinese company and they're the
best drone makers out there
like all these fpv drones are great but
there's no company really I mean there's
like
like Tango and that's yeah but they just
build components seriously yeah yeah I
don't I don't know of that many um like
companies that actually cut frames these
like like TBS team will actually
probably has people that they just like
yeah have you heard of pyro drone no
yeah
I don't know if he's picking anymore but
he's got some pretty good have you heard
of the floss no it's an old one uh so
you might not be relevant anymore
I mean why do you think it is that it's
hard to commercialize fpv drones because
DJ I tried it but nobody's really going
for their fpv drones I think there's a
really big stigma on drones like a lot
of people that I talk to have a negative
impression of them like yeah they're
being used to spy on people
yeah they're just too powerful it's like
they could but people don't want to go
more into technology they want to slow
down technology
because
I think of cat I think it's because of
capitalism
because
if a few people get all the resources
and power than any new technology can
only be used to hurt you and you know
instinctively that technology is
not going to be your friend
it's only going to help concentrate
power further so they just have this
react reactionary
reaction to technology
yeah
because they understand the system man
but it's like technology
can actually set us free
I don't think technology is bad I don't
think you should take out your hatred of
inequality
on technology
while you're busy doing that I'll be
learning how to fly a drone eventually
once it starts working
in the meantime I'm just sitting here
getting yelled at by my girlfriend and
did she actually owe you no that's good
appreciate it again
yeah she get pissed off yeah how are you
guys been dating five months okay
what something that happens is like I'll
be joking
and it'll sound like really [__] up
and she'll be like why would you say
that that's like a [__] up thing to
say like uh because that'll either have
to commit to the joke or bail out
immediately
and sometimes I'll come in and be like
no seriously I was just joking
they should be like novice think about
it think about what you said and how old
is she how horrible that is no uh she's
25.
decently
okay
so have you seen the 10th episode
10th anniversary episode of kill Tony no
I haven't seen it yet
oh hold on once again hold on
oh I see
okay
yeah it was amazing
that's so crazy that we both went for
the mouse at the same time
so this is an optimal motor Direction
because
if you're racing
your propellers are spinning outwards I
mean if you crash or just land in grass
with a normal propeller orientation
where they're spinning this way you're
going to get grass and [__] like all
over your drone rather if there's any
outwards that kicks all the grass out oh
you have a clean drum okay so it's not
looks good so that's better I mean does
it affect the performance at all yeah I
don't think so nice so it's just the
same performance but One Direction makes
it cleaner yeah
is the same on the back side too it
kicks it out instead of in it's
beautiful
kick it all out
foreign
how dangerous is grass to a drone's
propellers not at all okay because
sometimes I make Leaves a mark on the
intellect screen yeah I guess it might
leave a mark but you could seriously cut
grass with
seriously these things are spinning fast
enough and those propellers are rigid
enough that they will cut the tip of
your finger off it is so sharp and
they're spinning super fast like I've
seen the really really gory injuries
that's the uh reason why they're so
[__]
why it's only been now that drones have
taken off because we don't we didn't
have the technology yet like drone races
that I've been to if they're indoor
races or if they're Spectators around
they have to put up a huge net for them
yeah drones don't because they lose
Slade proof nut you know radio
transmission sometimes yeah they crash
all the time
I was really hoping that this would be
easy
man
it's not armed how can you tell us it's
like it won't well the motor should
start spinning when it arms
and they're not and I've got it like so
I have
I'm sure it's because I didn't [__] with
the thing I was [__] with it a lot
trying to get it to arm it could be
sure
yeah the 10th year anniversary show
comes out next Monday
I don't know if I'm spoiling anything
but that's logically when it would come
out
I guess not Saturday it was filmed on
the Saturday
yeah I uh cut my career trip short to go
to the 10th year anniversary show
and went to it and let's just say that
what happened happened and it's all
recorded and going out live on cable
Tony on Monday really excited to see
this yeah I mean it's already been out
if you paid the money for it well yeah
that's why I haven't seen it because you
have to pay for it and cheese that's
coming out soon anyways
but it's like you get to see it live
which is rare kill Tony never happens
live anymore so it's sad
pre-arm yeah so this should be what's
called air mode which is really cool
um and maybe this is why it's not
working I don't really know
S I guess
what did I set the notification maybe
just maybe
[Music]
so um
there was actually a new story about uh
Trump and how uh he said that he was uh
reading a classified document and he
knew it was classified
and he was looking at it anyways with
like AIDS and like a reporter
so they have it on tape
that he knew he was classified and he
was showing them so he knowingly broke
the law which like if he did did it
unknowingly she still broke the law like
why does it matter that he knew
but apparently he knew about it which
makes it worse
so
I mean
obviously he's gonna do that
I really want this one to do Ox too no
ox1 but I'm pretty sure
so it's on now
under the people you met who was the
funniest person off stage
probably
I mean the person that is the most
entertaining for me
is probably Joe Rogan just because
he's so good at talking and he's such a
pure genuine person
and he has interesting stories
so maybe this will work
you know sometimes
you see someone working on something and
you're like
that's better than I could do
what's the use of me chiming in at this
point
my only job
so not piss him off that might work
hopefully I'll figure it out
there's a button it's in this software
it's not like turned on
so you got the uh
um
should we test it out I don't know why
it's still beeping though
it's fine it always beeps
so should we test out the arm button oh
it's spinning yeah
that means that the battery's dead
oh God
yeah you didn't bring a spare right
are you sure
maybe there's somewhere you didn't
expect chicken chicken
yeah
the character
did you bring any other bag
but this one I just bumped up on
chartreuse so hopefully it'll charge
it's at 14.7 volts so it just needs to
get up to like 15.
okay but in the meanwhile you wanna
figure out how to stop it beeping yeah
or some other thing what else do we need
to do that's pretty much it we just
needed to get it to and then like after
you fly it then we can adjust the rates
and like okay just to tell how you're
comfortable playing it oh so this is
just the average setting yeah because
I'll just get used to it that this is
very good English
like the actual character like to fight
characteristics of the yeah that's funny
flight characteristic because they say
about uh car the intangible is the
driving characteristics like how it
drives
so I'm going to figure out my
personality in the air exactly
I'm actually just looking for most of
you don't even have a personality on the
ground
so what's your
flying characteristics
obviously like I had no mess with those
things I I will change these uh Max
velocity degrees per second yeah
um
and then with the Expo
it's like
as you know just like let's say if you
have to do something I left the cat out
on the porch on accident all day
where's it at now it's at the my
girlfriend's house
and oh you left it on the porch at her
house yeah and like I don't like the cat
so she thinks like I'm trying to kill it
now which I don't know am I trying to
kill the cat you just turned like
I was honestly not trying to kill the
cat
[Laughter]
but that cat is annoying as [__] totally
unrelated to me [__] up and locking
it outside on the porch on a Texas
summer
but it's revived like it's probably
stronger you know it has more character
yeah
it's gonna go one day without water
you know what we could do is just leave
it out there with a bowl of water the
Drone or the cat
oh the Drone Vietnam
they can make drones waterproof now they
can that conformal coating
oh is that like a little spray that you
spray into it I've seen it mostly it's
like a like a nail polish thing and you
just like paint it over the because the
motors are waterproof already
and it's the batteries or the internals
yeah so you have to like the batteries
are actually pretty solid too it's
really just the flight controller so you
just have to spray it
it's interesting
you can't use one of those Foams from
Home Depot
you probably could but then so the thing
with conformal coating is if you need to
do any sort of soldering or like work on
your board afterwards it makes it kind
of hard yeah
well everything's waterproof up to a
certain depth and time yeah
yeah and um
that's apparent with this submarine that
just got a lot yeah it's waterproof up
to 1 000 feet but it's going two
thousand
foreign
so uh
these are like people that you can like
copy their profile their flight profile
whatever it's nice I have a six inch
ramp
yeah dude it's like
above average
another drone yeah I know I'm joking
dude this isn't succession
yeah dead cat do you like dead cat
wait no the formation instead of like
flying X or whatever oh I see dead cat
yeah that's where the the front is
sorted to the side instead of in front
so that you can get better shots
I don't understand why people are not
filming their drone doing the flips
because I want to see that [__]
flipping around I don't want to just see
the front end
whoa okay this looks like
looks like my hometown finds [__] find
it thanks oh so this is like showing you
what you'll see on the OSD
that shit's gonna be on there that's
gonna be annoying being like
do you want any of this stuff on here
uh yeah you need this to see when the
battery's going out right
Jesus
now maybe we'll purchase like
it's up
it's like super zoomed in how do you
like zoom out
yeah put everything to the side I don't
want anything like in the middle so that
you can see when you're flying yeah
what the [__]
that's the reception I want the battery
and the reception right next to each
other
a milliamp hours
that amps what is the volts amps and
milliamp hours the volts are
how much juice you have a million of
hours the capacity of the battery
and so it should like that is probably
showing you so right so far oh how much
have you used but you know so 690 698
well 42 should be the capacity then 42
is amps so that's like that's the right
okay yeah how fast it's pulling and 69
is
how much left or the Max Capacity or how
much is left it's either how much is
left or how much you've used I can't
remember okay
and that's the reception
which like your um your transmitter will
like call that [__] out
I'll tell you
um altitude that's ten meters like where
it's starting from it has no idea like
what
what well uh yeah we can keep it and
then I'll probably delete it if it's
useless
you can control each LED that's so cool
we don't have to go over that no you I'm
trying to find the the beeper
setting
should we Google it yeah
yeah I was sick
oh my god when I let it out I was like
oh [__] I can't forget to
bring it back in but then the Uber was
like two minutes away and then he
started texting me and I freaked out
yeah Ubers get so mad at you if you show
up late
they're like
What's this called again what kind of
Jersey that's called evoke
you think five or something
I don't know
what you're gonna look at the beeping
yeah but this seemed more important
I thought you figured it out
how to get a term
maybe I changed I got it to recognize
that first channel uh-huh
thank you
yeah I haven't smoked weed in like three
days
and I kind of feel like I'm Dumber for
being sober yeah like I feel like I'm
not I'm not as sharp as like you want to
break that streak that's not smoking
weed yeah
I'm not like quitting forever I just
thought maybe it'd be good to not be
still intelligent
but I'm starting to think like why yeah
it's just like an extra thing like where
you're choosing happiness like let me
choose to be happy today let me bump
this up a notch
like I told at least four customers to
bag their own button groceries today
do they deserve it oh for sure
yeah I mean
you gotta have some limits and
boundaries or else you're not gonna be
mentally healthy
I think subconsciously I'm trying to
like
get fired from Trader Joe's so that I'll
have more time to focus on comedy
subconsciously
that's funny
the beeping
all right
what time do you want to go okay
okay
um
so how are you doing with the ladies
much better than I was
what do you attribute the sudden
improvement too uh just me deciding what
I want like me making the choice to
pursue a certain person WoW instead of
settling for whatever comes to me
you were enamored with a person recently
uh no I just found out that
the sexual way yeah but prior to that I
really thought that she was out of my
league yeah like this chick is way too
hard for me she'd never be into me and
well honestly that's the only thing that
was keeping me from so even if even
though everything was good to go you
were holding yourself back somehow
that's unfortunate but now you're not
and now you're with this beautiful
person I wouldn't say whip but I mean I
guess you guys are courting each other
for each other that's amazing what a
success story you might eat the molly
tamales not tamales some Molly some
Molly yeah oh Molly the drug
well that's cool yeah I'm glad that it's
happening
if she's been pretty attractive wow
she's actually like the most attractive
that's really cool
well hopefully she sees this and knows
that she is better than you yeah no she
I've kind of tried to turn it back on
that like every time the only time I
told her she's better me is the first
time I saw her I was like why are you
here what are you doing yeah and then
after that I realize that's unattractive
and I should probably just act like
that's weird because then it makes it
seem transactional like oh you're
getting more out of this yeah like what
does that even mean and humans are weird
too like they'll start believing that
[__] if you actually think that you're
not worth this person's time they're
gonna start thinking that too yeah the
subconscious this the parts of your life
where you're just reacting you don't
want that to be filled with insecurities
and doubt
had
yes
thank you
Telemetry locked
I uh
proposed to my ex-girlfriend
like
last
October
or whatever yeah and I used a drone to
film it
that's pretty cool did you have way
points uh it was I just I we went to the
beach
are you familiar with like Alki Beach
yes at least and
um I took him on the motorcycle I think
I had the German follow us I was like
wait I want to stop and get a drone
video and I decided like follow us for a
little bit until we got like right
around the corner okay so use the Drone
as an excuse to propose to her kind of
yeah she knows that I was always like
taking out my drone for videos and
things like that and that's why women
can never trust drones because they're
so useful to surprise [__] with
people that deliver a joint to your
neighbor down the street
um
over there
oh hell yeah [__] yeah yes it's spinning
oh yes yeah oh my God [__] yeah why did
it stop you disarmed it okay and then
look I
guess this is a beeper
so if you were [__] you can't find
your drone yeah push this button okay
and what's our the arm is the this side
okay
okay let's pop some propellers on this
[__]
they should be going out let's get
outwards it uh
okay
yeah
yeah okay cool oh yeah
wow
is it even dark outside
it's about to be
oh I have a show I have to go too soon
okay
I might need a ride to my girlfriend's
house but I also don't want to ride on a
motorcycle
I understand
what is the use of a motorcycle and yes
over a car on either side which one to
take
I have always been my motorcycle for
involvements the first reason is that
I'm obsessed
far more likely building so you're
always in [__] mode
trying to monitoring you can't really
trying to get it back focus on if you
want to look good for the female gender
that's cool and then the other reason
can you can you get places faster
wowing is obvious parking is amazing um
but yeah I
make sure those are the right propellers
but yeah I mean women
love it
um I just don't know how you get faster
on a motorcycle without breaking the law
oh you don't so you break the law you
break the laws how so I just tried to I
mean I don't want to die and I want to
be doing why so I try to be saved from
you like five minutes
yeah I
I break the law bite I think it's almost
dangerous not to break the law because
if you're just sitting at an
intersection just waiting for someone to
hit you yeah it's better to be
it's better to be somewhere safer
people
so yeah I can't seriously I got rid of
leaving something called my house and
your doctor all the way to trade videos
and like it's a I try to lose him by
driving over I didn't have this much
I want some [__] so this was crazy you
know I was like driving sidewalks
outside claims it was [__] dude in
this giant lifted Dodge pickup truck was
just like fish killing all over the
place like he was also driving everyone
and I was driving [__] furious all I
did was drive around from like he came
up to an intersection there's nobody
going and he was on his phone and I
wasn't trying to stop so I just rolled
down and they saw me lost it so you you
blew the red light it wasn't a light it
was it was a stop sign so he said he was
distracted and he didn't he was
distracted he left at least a car space
between him and the intersection and it
was you know you're supposed to stop
there because there's traffic it's in my
neighborhood so there's no traffic there
I just went around
wait it was a stop sign yeah yeah okay
so he was taking forever at the stop
sign yeah like as I was coming up like
I guess and so he got spooked probably
he didn't get spooky got pissed but you
got well he probably got pissed because
he didn't expect it and he's like oh
someone's criticizing how I'm driving
but like the level that you deal with
insane as well that's probably why if it
made sense he probably wouldn't have
taken it to that level but since he's a
crazy person I call the police it was
nuts dude he was like I wasn't driving
this this first thing I was driving my
black one that moves like like anybody
it's like I couldn't I couldn't you know
if she had a better one you could have
run away from her if I had the
motorcycle today
yeah or you want to tighten them even
more well you didn't miss
like when I found my rose I I buy
lawyers that are reverse dreaded so that
as they in they tighten themselves
these ones are all the same direction
thank you
yeah no idea it's supposed to be
done
you know I'm outside
mixing something my girl if it wants uh
geomet blackout curtains
yeah I could sleep in here forever
foreign
that they're like oh [__] I'm on the
live stream and I might be revealing
something embarrassing about myself like
my thoughts and my videos
foreign
so is that thing good to go if I just
plug it in it'll charge it the whole
thing yeah okay
so we get to go should we test it out
where should we go test them out
black out here
okay
let's do